we enter the second weekend of this
conflict we're going to be looking today
at the southern um part of ukraine in
particular as you were hearing there
about these two ceasefire zones with our
defense and security analyst michael
clark professor tell us a bit about the
ceasefire this doesn't appear to have
been successful does it yeah yes a
couple of days ago i said i didn't think
the russians would agree to a
humanitarian corridor i was wrong about
that except that they have agreed to
minor corridors they've never done it
before and it doesn't look as if they're
holding in theory there's supposed to be
a corridor for mario paul to take out
200 000 people a corridor from uh
vulnerable
to take out 15 000 people we think to
zaparizia uh that was the plan
that plan came into operation at seven
o'clock this morning uk time but it
doesn't seem to be working because
neither corridor is is open both of them
have been shelled it's not clear that
they will work or whether this is just a
false start okay and if we look at the
military advance in the south it does
seem to have been much more successful
than in the north why is that yes i mean
the russians are making a lot more
progress in the south mainly because
in crimea they've got shorter lines of
communication they've controlled crimea
since 2014
and in fact they've been planning this
it seems for quite a long time so the
forces in the south have been able to
get going in the way they obviously
planned to do whereas the forces in the
north have had a much heavier harder
time as they were coming in because
they're coming into hostile territory so
in the south they've had much more
success and this territorial strip
now from the uh the separatist regions
and the donbass right through to the
edge of a desert the port now looks as
if it is consolidating itself although
it's certainly not straightforward and
they're pushing north too here out of
kurzon yes uh i mean the the uh capture
location was quite important and now in
the southern bug valley the river the
sudden bug which is a very complex
series of river systems they're pushing
north that may take some time of course
but it's the obvious thing to do as they
push westwards towards odessa so they'll
try and expand northwards eventually to
link up their northern front with the
southern front although they're quite a
long way apart at the moment
and in the north i mean we've been
talking about this the last few days it
does feel like the military advance has
stalled it hasn't really moved in four
days yeah nothing much has happened
there's been a great deal of violence of
course um and the the famous convoy the
enormous convoy that is making its way
to kiev which hasn't moved for four days
is as is a matter of some interest to us
all in fact there's very interesting
detail major general chukawiski um who
is a two-star general he was shot in a
sniper attack uh yesterday along with uh
two other senior officers a divisional
commander and a regimental commander
those people shouldn't be anywhere near
the front line i mean sukhovitskiy was
four ranks above the rank of fighting on
the front line the fact that they are on
the front line getting themselves shot
indicates that they're going forward to
try to find out what the problem is and
obviously have a few choice words with
their junior commanders the fact that
they're doing that indicates that they
know they've got problems they're just
not moving in the way that they
obviously expected to do 10 days ago
that's very interesting and to the east
of kiev you can see the russian advances
there that yellow zone what what's
happening here and how how close is it
coming to kiev they're
making their way but they've got
problems at chernyhiv uh problems are
still at kharkiv which is being
brutalized at the moment so they've
tried to screen those cities by just
moving around them but if you screen a
city you've always got the problem that
soldiers in that city will move out and
attack and there's quite a lot of
evidence that the ukrainians are
although they can't mount a counter
offensive in a strategic sense they can
counter attack locally and they do seem
to be doing that up in the north and
it's slowing the russians down
okay thank you so much professor clark
um so there you go jane you can see in
the north it does seem to have stalled
somewhat but that doesn't mean that the
russian advance has stopped
and of course keeve is surrounded
and that is the ultimate prize for the
russians jane